all right hi how is everybody
I'm Tim actually I'll fix this for you
I'm from Australia so that was pretty
that was a pretty cool new joke I'm
allowed to do that because I'm actually
from Australia so that's alright
CSS cough god it's been such a big day
today it's been such a good day I feel I
feel so privileged to be amongst like
the speakers that we've had
it's truly special and everyone has been
like so insanely helpful I had this
weird moment earlier today where my I
didn't bring like a German convert a
plug and my laptop was getting getting
low and Mac started doing like power
saving things and eventually just
stopped responding and I had to like do
that thing where you hold the power
button down and I felt really weird I
was like I was smothering it with a
pillow it's like Shh it's gonna be all
over soon that was I was a bit strange
so it was like yeah there's been such a
huge variety of talks today this is this
is a little bit of a different talk
because you're definitely not going to
learn anything if anything it's kind of
like an unlearning unlearning kind of
talk I've definitely seen the sketch
notes from my talks before and it's just
basically an empty page with my name
written in the centre so take your
thinking caps off we're gonna go on a
great great adventure I want to talk
about fun I want to talk about having
fun with the code and having fun with
the tools that we have because we have
so much power and we have so much
ability to create such crazy cool things
you know I'm happy to like talk about
CSS all day and I can talk about kind of
like the frameworks and stuff but in a
weird way I kind of feel like I'm
talking about building a kite and I'm
not actually talking about flying the
kite and flying the kite is the best
thing so that's that's kind of what this
talk is about this is my qualification
CSS for babies that's where I learned
everything so the first thing that I
want to talk about is this is this kind
of framework I you've kind of seen these
like star wipes going on actually
everything in this whole talk is
epileptic I'm sorry I really like I just
put oh there he goes well there we go
here's the CSS for that it's using mask
image with an SVG which is fantastic it
kind of gives you some cool things like
I can change it to hearts I can do a hot
which was really nice like a thumbs up
maybe some subliminal messaging there
like Tim's a cool guy Tim's a cool guy
Tim's a cool guy Tim's a cool guy
I put I put him a stash in that for Nick
actually which was nice yeah I also I
also put a donkey in that which is
technically an [ __ ]
so I was pretty proud of myself there
they hit my new in maturity levels but
let's stick with the star I found this
great video it was actually a tribute to
star wipes in a star wipe format which
was which was kind of like the
inspiration to want to make a
presentation framework because there's
so many this reveal Jay asked is like I
know there's a thousand systems to do
these things but none of them offered
star wipes which which was a little bit
distressing anyway this is kind of what
I'm talking about when I say fun like I
I really like to run into something and
kind of hit it head-on really football
and then kind of start exploring and
start going like a little bit deeper and
a little bit deeper and a little bit
deeper to see kind of where it can go
and what what we can kind of do with
with what we're creating in school
school in Australia was pretty laid-back
I was kind of like a little bit of a
lazy kid and I know CSS is is something
that you can kind of use lazily and you
can use aggressively and powerfully and
I sometimes I find myself leaning kind
of on the lazy side but it was also a
great way to kind of describe things so
here's me this is a weird format that's
the number I decided I was probably
about this 63rd thousandth Tim Holman in
the world which is you know it's just
nice I'm about seven thousand pixels
tall probably um
yeah mm wide I've got some padding now
that it's summer well summers ending but
hopefully I can get rid of that padding
this is kind of what I did with my
assignments in school you had to submit
assignments like it's three pages or
four pages of five pages or ten pages it
was particularly bad and you could kind
of cheat the system so like books I
bought a box it's a piece of paper of
course first increase the padding like
then you're gonna have less words in
each line it's gonna stuck in our faster
next increase the word spacing suddenly
like one page is at least two pages now
increase the letter spacing when you're
really like slip that one through the
teachers it's a good way to do it and
it's the lazy way it's the lazy approach
it's the Tim Holman tried and trusted
method for for development so I kind of
wanted to put something like that into
this into this presentation that was
kind of like oh you know I've got to
talk for for 30 minutes or so what's
like the the padding decrease that I can
put on this so like into the framework
here I kind of build a system to like
slow down the transition so I can really
like play it slow make sure I get the
time that I'm kind of going for yeah you
know and that I can speed it up again it
can be like fostering the furious oh
that's not fast enough
Vin Diesel that's me what I'm developing
I liked I actually really like these CSS
puns in this I guess there's a ton of
them online there was a few like reddit
threads and this is like a nice one Lego
display:block I like it because I
understand it that's the main thing
Titanic float:none yeah so it's not in
bad taste so well no they didn't even
know about CSS back then periodic
display table that's a good one
muffins ready over for wide visible if I
made them you'll never get to that
status Chuck Norris's color is badass
naturally this is really cool I'm from
Australia that's the that's the rotation
that I have naturally in my eyes
everyone sitting on the roof right now
this was kind of me when I found these
these plums I was like I'm gonna be
great at this I'm like I can be a funny
guy I can make some weird jokes and all
of them turned out to be really
depressing actually
so like here's me here are my abs
display:none here's me here's my beard
now I've got like a patchy SVG mask over
it for the rest of my life this is my
regular transition speed like that's
pretty accurate
when seamless arrives at the door BAM
I'm fast as anything do you have
seamless here for me no like Chinese
delivery what I'm preparing for this
slow is anything I kind of like really
got bogged down I kind of got bogged
down building the system this is me when
I'm making something and I stop to think
of ideas do you ever get that feeling
when you're when you're
well doing something and your your head
is just going off it's like if I wasn't
developing this these are the other
things that I would be developing that's
like me all the time I'm just like I'm
building this but we're gonna be cool if
I wasn't doing this and I could do
something else and I just want to start
something start something start
something something start something so
when I made this I started to make this
presentation to talk about a fun with
CSS and I spent most of the time
building the framework which is which is
now what I'm talking about I kind of
have like this nervousness when I'm
developing I don't know where I came
from to be honest probably like
untrustworthy Australian Internet where
I just like saved everything I'm just
like safe safe safe safe safe safe safe
three times I press the Save button at
least three times on every file that I
want to save I built this into here so
like every slide I can kind of save my
there we go
I can save me I save my status save
where I'm at keep going it's a nice you
know it's a nice little fullback here's
me clapping applauding myself like clean
girl free so this was like my list of
fears when when I was giving a
conference talk like everybody kind of
has like a few little fears obviously
the first one was that I wasn't feeling
the time which which I can defeat by
slowing the transition slowing the
slides down a lot I might do it you know
I've got a clock here if I'm if I'm not
feeling in time
that's definitely what's gonna happen
everything's gonna break down you know I
can't really do that much about that but
I can definitely like save my position
on every single slide every single time
and the next one was like that I'm gonna
forget what I'm gonna say which is you
know that's a huge fear right like
public speaking is a huge fear you come
up and you're like oh what was I going
to say what was I gonna say so I needed
to build in speaking notes obviously to
this this presentation system so I did
it like this you know here here up come
my hand so you can actually will see it
you know it's kind of nice I'm like if I
have trouble seeing things you guys can
see it as well it was it was a nice
system that was actually that was
papyrus if anyone asked I actually found
somebody the other day
combined comic sans and papyrus into a
new super font move-over Helvetica
papyrus sans is here it was fantastic
this was the CSS that I used to make my
hands look less ugly in there a little
bit of blur you know Photoshop is dead
we already learned it today a little bit
of brightness a little bit of grayscale
take some color out of these
bad boys maybe I'm born with it maybe
it's mabeline all right
really I should just like blow them
completely and you wouldn't you wouldn't
have to deal with you wouldn't have to
deal with those hands are really weird
when you look at them up close and
especially when you're developing
looking at hands I kind of had this
problem when I built the system to to
give me to give me notes where I was
kind of like rehearsing and practicing
the speech as a practicing the talk as
you do and I kind of found that I wasn't
actually learning it like I was you know
I was kind of falling back into those
lazy ways and I was cheating again
so like every slide I'd be like what's
that like this you know this doesn't
really make sense I'm like what was I
trying to do there and and of course I
would like get out the hands and it's
like oh why why can't I stop cheating so
I kind of had to build it this thing
where after i after I try to cheat for a
few times it starts messing with the
text you know it gets gets worse it gets
worse
we're like checking you know that would
be bad
and then eventually it's like you're
over you're done Tim you're you're in
big trouble I kind of like this concept
I kind of liken it to Bilbo in the ring
like he kind of relies on this thing and
it just just kind of goes a little bit
crazy in the end and the concept of like
computers getting mad at us and kind of
like intentionally building something to
to hurt people and to ruin people's
experience I kind of really like that
idea I think it's like a weird way of
thinking when you're when you're trying
to make an experience negative on you're
trying to make something a little bit
worse so trying to make something a
little bit weird and a little bit more
wrong because nobody really does that
that much and passwords are a big one
possible is just like well it's kind of
like a pet peeve of mine where you put
in a password and it's like oh your
password is too it's too simple like
that's kind of an insult it's like Tim
your simple person you can't you can't
remember anything else and I kind of
like feel a little bit hurt by that
every single time I get her I feel like
my password 10 years ago if I use it
again now it's like the technology's
changed we understand that right the
technology has changed you can crack
passwords faster so I kind of my
Possible's got weaker over time and and
I kind of wanted to play around with
that this is a website that I built with
friend is called the passive-aggressive
password machine my my my path to world
dominance of course of all's around
having my own password algorithm to
detect strengths so when you're kind of
talking that the idea was like you're
kind of being talking down to like
really you called that a password do you
even know what a password is that's what
I feel when I says my possible speak I'm
not angry I'm just disappointed
my mom's used that one on me before and
it stings the most right to your core
you never you never really forget though
and try hard I like blah blah you know
it gets I got some numbers in there in
the end it's like you're not even gonna
remember this part that's okay because
at least you're proud of me now yeah I
kind of get like a little bit yeah I
kind of get a little bit down when I see
these things and and it's kind of nice
to to kind of explore them and you know
sometimes you get a little bit sad maybe
I'm making some jokes in the
presentation and the not quite going
over as well so I kind of built in
motivational notes so like if I press em
it's like Tim you can do it amazing like
you're doing great thank you Oh God oh
it's so nice isn't it I feel really good
now and then I was like maybe Tim you're
gonna get you're gonna get a little bit
over you're gonna get a little bit too
on top so I have some demotivational
ones as well all right let's keep it
happy let's keep it happy I kind of got
a lot I got pretty distracted building
this whole thing you know that's that's
kind of the crux of it I built in x-ray
mode oops so it goes all kind of x-ray
if you try to get speaking those in
x-ray mode you get skeleton hands that's
nice that's a must in anything really
it's on x-ray off I can like I know if
you can see it here I can like beach
ball beach ball my mouth you know just
in case I need to have some unenforced
technical difficulties and get out of
here
it's a weird thing when you just kind of
go down the rabbit hole and there's
nothing really stopping you you just
kind of get deeper and deeper and deeper
and deeper strange yeah so that's that's
star wipe
the the presentation system of the
future but I should I should move on
from there
but is this fun is this the kind of fun
thing this is the stuff that I enjoy
making the most like I I know there's
nothing really holding you back there's
no one telling me there's no one telling
anyone here really like this is the
wrong way to to kind of enjoy yourself
and to make weird things and kind of
like surprise and delight everybody that
you're that you're going through I this
is a good slide isn't it
no notes there I was a bit of a
prankster in school and and kind of as
as I've grown up you know the pranks
kind of evolved and they use like in
school you have like a pencil or a glue
stick and you put on someone's chair and
it's the funniest thing
and as you know as you kind of grow into
a new set of tools your your pranks
evolve a little bit and there's a lot of
cool stuff that you can do with CSS
that's the equivalent of chucking a
slice of cheese on someone's bass
there's this file I don't know if
anyone's seen it custom CSS and it lives
in the chrome lives in like the chrome
like root of your of your laptop and any
CSS that you put in this file will run
on every single page that person goes to
it's it's fantastic it's really really
when I found this like I ran straight to
the bathroom and giggled for like five
minutes
I hadn't even done anything I was like
oh we are gonna have so much fun here so
he wrote like a little bash script that
that would inject whatever I wanted into
this into this and when somebody leaves
that laptop open I would kind of go onto
that computer and you know get it out of
github and I just paste it into a
terminal close the terminal delete the
history of the browser and it's
completely gone and this is so good so
custom CSS it is God's gift to man
so this is a good one this was the the
hue rotation put it on everything forget
it throw out the rulebook there is no
rulebook you know we understand this
thing we could probably look at it and
go oh something strange is happening
here but I don't quite tell what it is
but you know if you do that to your
sister or your workmates
no idea here's like I mean I include
that little effect or if it loads this
is it you've got to do it really subtle
like you have to have like this is ten
seconds this is too fast you don't want
to do it in ten seconds you want to do
it over 100 seconds you want somebody on
Google to just be like a little bit
questioning if they're going crazy
just a little bit
I mean it doesn't end there it doesn't
end there
this is a good one a lot of things use
the class an ID logo you can rotate them
and this is kind of a broad this is what
I call like a broad spectrum prank
really because this is good this is kind
of it doesn't ruin your experience
you're gonna see it and you're gonna be
on google and you're gonna see the logo
kind of rotating like Oh Google's doing
one of those things today yeah it must
be it must be like the invention of the
merry-go-round or something Netflix it
does I just kind of like put this on for
a while tried it out and you kind of
forget when you've done this to somebody
because it's not that harmful but every
now and then like I've had this like
passing like I've kind of overheard it
in the office was like have you noticed
that all the websites online are
spinning it's been happening for the
past few weeks I'm like oh [ __ ] I left
it on this guy's okay I left it there
Google's the same logo no it's a nice
it's a nice subtle subtle messing
sometimes you can just make everything
grayscale there's suddenly everyone
thinks that they're a little bit
colorblind this is cruel and it's kind
of especially strange to have you open
Firefox everything's fine go back to
Chrome me like oh my chrome is just
screwed everything's black and white
doesn't doesn't make any sense this is
what I actually tried to do first I
tried to yeah took Oh Tim you've gone
too far you've gone too far it doesn't
work it doesn't work I was I was so
excited I particularly like this because
it refuses to recognize papyrus as a
font in the first place it's just gonna
sit there in the white why would that
happen
I mean papyrus sans is fine just make
all the links hot pink you know just a
subtle thing that's harmless do what you
want I kind of like this idea again of
like making experiences worse for people
you know sometimes sometimes you can
kind of unlock some new ideas there and
you can kind of like find these new
treasure troves of weirdness and and you
get a little bit of perspective as well
you're kind of going down this rabbit
hole of making something worse and you
can kind of get a good perspective and
thing like oh you know everything's not
that bad really
this is a great image of a pop up you
know everyone has seen these on the web
Google is kind of penalizing for
penalizing your your search ranking for
hitting a web page with these pop-ups
this is like demonic spawn of a pop up
you know that because it's got sound one
that's like checkbox amazing it's kind
of selling itself it like consumes the
whole screen I've had to build pop-ups
like this before I've worked in
advertising I I don't fully believe in
like the the self-righteous web
developer where you're like I absolutely
refuse to build this because it's your
job sometimes you have to do these
things and I kind of like this
experience of making things worse again
I just keep saying and I'm a bad person
social media is kind of spamming is is a
good example of that and this is this is
a website that I built trying to think
like you know the pop up will come up
and say like tweet this page we need you
to share this like thousand Facebook
Likes we need likes and I kind of built
this library it's got like a little bit
of subliminal messaging in the
background and wherever you move your
mouse on the webpage the tweet button
actually sticks to it that's fifty four
thousand tweets right there I actually
have to filter it out of my feed because
it's annoying as [ __ ] it's really
frustrating I haven't seen this in the
wild but I actually am convinced that is
a very effective mechanism I should go
to the next like spam Kampf and be you
know report my findings it's weird like
that it's making things worse it makes
you kind of understand that you know
everything is okay interactions a big
one this is a website that I built for a
friend who who has this app called
authentic weather and it's kind of like
a weather app that is it's a little bit
brutally honest it's like it's [ __ ]
rainy right now look outside you don't
need to know the weather and that's kind
of like a simple site you know it's not
it's not too crazy it's got some like
Instagram things get your sunglasses
it's very cozy and and this is this was
kind of a nice web site to build it
didn't look particularly bad it wasn't
all that sweet bones in the wrong place
whoever built that is terrible yeah it
doesn't really like represent a big
challenge but it's kind of nice to build
and and I kind of like to ask myself
whenever I'm building something like
what can I get out of this
whether I'm gonna go in a weird
direction and make something worse or
I'm gonna make something better what
what small amount can I gain where can I
inject some creativity where can I have
some fun and this was the button I'll
let me zoom you know this was like the
blue buttons on that on that on the side
that said like click this and you can
download the app and click this and you
can get the Android app and and I kind
of wanted to like put something fun in
there so I kind of injected like a
little bit of a story into this button
so when you hover it's like how are you
today
I'm doing well thanks for asking just
keep hovering it's a good life being a
button the work is hard but enjoyable
yeah it's great save me
it's nice right it doesn't do it doesn't
do any harm like it's it's you know some
people can kind of breeze by this it's
like that little bit of surprise and
delight and a little bit of fun and I
could take this out of the website and I
could put it on like code pen or I could
put it kind of in an isolated place and
I feel happy that it exists and I feel
like a little bit proud that it's you
know that it's there and then it's
around and this is the nice way again a
kind of looking at things and looking at
interaction of course there is the bad
way again that I keep saying that's like
always two sides this is what funny gif
isn't it there's two sides of a coin
this was this was a library that had
built gift links this was this was again
like playing with hover interactions and
the kind of thought was was like how can
a computer kind of punch you in the face
so so when your hobby is like you know
there's orange orange like since the
dawn of the internet the world has been
asking why a hover interaction so boring
only recently has a new paradigm arisen
to solve these emotionally crippling
problems designers call them gift links
this is my favorite gift on the internet
actually it's like a toy from the 70s
60s maybe before toys were fun before
the game boy and he's getting brain
damage I'm sure of it trying to look
like I'm having a good time it's a
little-known fact but 9 out of 10 UX
specialists
I agree the gift length right a richer
more enhanced user experience which can
be tailored specifically for the
enjoyment of your audience and and this
is kind of like a library that I that I
kind of created just to just to do this
effect it's nothing really crazy it's
nothing really big it's on github with
the rest of the stuff and this is kind
of a weird one like I got some emails
like Tim you are actually ruining the
internet you're making the world a worse
place I kind of want to print that and
just stick it on my wall and I've seen
that one kind of out in the wild it's a
bit of a funny thing sometimes I kind of
like exploring like the borders and and
kind of finding like weird little
browser quirks and things that you can
what did I say then that was funny I
don't know yeah it can kind of like jump
over these little spaces and and so this
wasn't this was one this is a website
that I built with the with the same
friend oh nice well it's all red and we
that's okay so this was like a website
for like a beard oil and when I kind of
go in it was like well I can put like a
little animation in the console there he
is like he's it's a nice beard and he's
winking
I spent 90% of the dev time on that
project building that instead of instead
of the rest of it and when he was kind
of like Tim just play around like do
something fun do something weird you
know that's kind of what I did I also
made the mistake of naming all my
classes off the types of beards soul
patch like old Dutch that was the
biggest mistake I've ever made it made
everything way more confusing you should
compile it into that after there's some
good research though oh yeah so this is
kind of like reaching over into into
another space and kind of playing around
this is another one it only works on Mac
now like when I released this it's like
Chrome patched the bug in like three
days and it's like you're cruel people I
was around four weeks before that but
when you when you when you kind of
scroll up and down on a Mac or an iOS
device you kind of noticed that little
spring effect that it has at the top and
when you're looking in JavaScript you
kind of get a negative number back
coming from the scroll position so I
could kind of use that too when you
scroll too far on either side I could
have something a little pop-up like a
little bit of a little bit of grumpy cat
I was upset at Chrome I filed a bug I
was like guys you're ruining my fun and
they were way more serious than I was in
that conversation so it didn't really
work out that we need to create this not
really right there's no there's no real
reason for us to do anything but we can
kind of come in and we can explore a
little bit and we can have a good time
this is a website that I built ages ago
months years two years ago the useless
web and this was kind of like the
website that got me into weird stuff I'd
say like you know when someone's like
how long have you been a developer I'm
like I've been like an unprofessional
web developer three years that's kind of
my answer when you press this button it
kind of takes you to these weird weird
websites this is a this is I don't know
that's a weird that's not a fun one
I'm just get something else this is just
a purple screen I think the URL is like
random color there we go let's see well
they're not lying there not lying there
that had noise this was just a domain
people kind of buy these buy these URLs
and kind of put something weird on their
cat bounce this is gonna be fun you know
it it's that like 49,000 tweets I mean I
could just tweet that every single day
for the rest of my life and die a happy
person anyway I could stay on here
forever it's like a huge time-suck it's
got it gets like millions of visitors
and everyone stays for about ten minutes
and I kind of like calculate it and it's
like over one month that consumes us
like years and years of man-hours I feel
like I've made a negative dent on the
whole economy of the world which is
something I'm very proud of personally
this was a funny little library that I
built elevated yes it's kind of weird
now because everyone's like oh you're
the guy that did this like really simple
thing but when you kind of scroll down
to the to the bottom and this I cut oh
this is going to take you back to the
top of the website
elevator music some nice thing about
I'm convinced this javascript library as
the key to world peace kind of weird
this is something that I was playing
around with recently nobody likes this
some it's always hit and miss you know
you'll spend a couple of weekends and
make something and people like oh this
was really great like that elevated yes
and sometimes you make something
anyone's like Tim go away and this was
one I'm kind of scared to go to his blue
screen of death ojs and there's a whole
seven tweets there because it's really
kind of horrific and you include this
when you start developing it was like
the dev tools have just been getting so
good everything's been getting so easy
and whenever any JavaScript error
happens on your page it just wipes out
the whole Dom it wipes out the whole
head of the page it spams your console
so you essentially can't find out what
the [ __ ] happened I mean and it just
looks like a blue screen though that's a
nice picture right there hopefully it
doesn't crash everything no it didn't
that's nice so yeah you know this is
this is kind of like what I'm making
this stuff you don't really like
thinking much I'm just kind of trying to
make something fun I'm kind of repeating
this point over and over and over again
but I kind of have no strong thoughts
one way or the other I'm not like big on
kind of arguing about these things
because it is for our own delight and
it's our own platform and we can do
whatever we kind of want to do
I found this function this is kind of
coming coming towards an end I work at
tumblr and I found this function in the
code was like generate dolphins thank
stop the presses I literally stopped the
presses I was like I'm not doing
anything until I understand what this is
because it's intriguing and and the code
it was like in this far corner of the
thing I'm like kind of reading it
through and like it seems to be
generating some kind of dolphin
somewhere where are the dolphins and and
I was kind of on slack it was like God
generate dolphins function where did
this come from
I found it eventually in the in there
audio player in tumblr when when songs
finished the psychic dolphins swimming
around you can kind of see it in the
visualizer there somebody was like oh
that's a shark because the tail fin is
up and down I was like I come from
Australia it's a dolphin let me but this
is kind of again it's like the surprise
and delight you know don't be
to have a little fun with what you're
doing don't be afraid to inject some
dolphins into your code put some weird
things put music to stuff make things
follow the mouse it doesn't really
matter where you go there's no wrong
answer and there's no wrong way to have
fun
and kind of like coming to a close this
was the deconstruction for that for the
generate dolphins when dolphins cry and
and I'm kind of a little bit sad now
that everything is kind of done but
cheers thank you
we can cool